hi in this video we would learn about
how steroid hormone works so steroid
hormones are actually produced from the
adrenal cortex or the gonads now these
steroid hormones are generally
glucocorticoids mineralocorticoids
androgens estrogens progesterone etc now
let's take an particular example like
from one of these steroids and try to
understand its mode of action at the
cellular and molecular level but if you
don't know that how these steroids are
synthesized inside of our body then you
should watch my other video which is in
the playlist and the link is given at
the end of this video so let's talk
about puberty in case of females the
breast size increased after the puberty
and it is due to the effect of its
trijet
let's see at molecular level how this
physiological phenomena that means
breast size increase is triggered by
estrogen so inside the breast just to
give you a sense of the anatomy there
are several lobules
and there are milk ducts they're majorly
adipose tissues these things increase in
size as a female is crossing her puberty
and going to adolescence now let's talk
about how is trojan can work at a
cellular level so let's talk about one
breast cell a cell of a epithelial cell
of the lobule and let's see how its size
would be modulated with the help of
estrogen so it's region like many other
steroid hormones work with the help of
intracellular receptors so what are
intracellular receptors as the name
suggests this are present in the
internal side of the cell they are not
displayed on the membrane surface now
they could be present in cytoplasm and
most of the steroid hormone receptors
are present in the cytoplasm and on
demand when the ligand is present them
move to the nucleus now let's look at
the structure of the steroid hormone
receptor so it has a ligand binding
domain which binds to the steroid
hormone it has a DNA binding domain
which bind to the response element and
it has some activation domain known as
af1 and af2 so from the gene when it is
transcribed it's roughly protein
structure look like this and in the DNA
binding domain there are defined motifs
which help to bind the DNA in a
sequence-specific manner and mostly
these motifs are zinc finger motifs we
would look at it in details okay so
let's look at the structure again so
here you have quite a lot of domains and
this is a segment of the DNA which shows
this kind of this kind of organization
so the transcription activation a
function one and transcription
activation function two domains help in
transcriptional activity while ligand
binding activation ligand binding domain
first of all binds to a ligand and also
help in dimerization we would understand
that why dimerization is important in a
second and ultimately DNA binding domain
has the function of DNA binding so all
of these things give rise to the protein
which is the intracellular receptor the
steroid hormone receptor which is able
to bind to the ligand now let's look at
how zinc finger motif which is present
in the DNA binding domain of this
receptor or steroid hormone receptor can
bind to the DNA now in the zinc finger
motif the zinc moiety of the same point
is coordinated by several residues such
as cysteine
cysteine or histidine but there are
amino acids which are protruding out
from the zinc finger motif which forms
hydrogen bond with the base pairs of DNA
in the major groove now this kind of
signaling is very different from other
signaling pathways such as Mac kinase
signaling pathway where the ligand binds
and several intracellular cascade gives
rise to a signal which is going to the
nucleus here the ligand binds to the
receptor and the receptor ligand
activated complex directly moved to the
nucleus instead of the other messengers
so here normally when the
ligand is not present for example in
this situation the estrogen is not
present or extra gene is low-level that
situation the intracellular receptor the
estrogen receptor is actually wrapped
around by a heat shock protein 90 and
unfolded state now when the ligand binds
this heat shock protein 90 releases this
intracellular receptor and it can now
move to the nucleus where it can bind to
specific response element present on the
DNA and these response elements are
known as hormone response element in
this case since it's estrogen we are
talking about
so it would be estrogen response element
and that might lead to transcriptional
activation we would look at what genes
are transcribed and how they are
relevant for in this particular
physiological process of breast
development now inside the DNA like on
the DNA there are sequences which are
hexameric sequences dispersed by random
nucleotides these are known as the
hormone binding element or hormone
response elements in this case it is
estrogen receptor response element now
the zinc finger domains of these
estrogen receptor would bind to that
hormone receptor element with specific
hydrogen bonding in the major groove of
the DNA and two of these monomeric units
of the istration receptor element would
dimerize using the ligand binding domain
and ultimately that would lead to
transcription of several genes out of
many genes that are transcribed few
remarkable RC meak cyclin d1 etc all of
them regulate cell cycle and cell growth
and that is how we can understand how
estrogen can modulate to orchestrate the
regul or regulate the development of the
secondary sexual characteristics in
females so that is how we understand how
the mechanism of action of a steroid
hormone is very different from the
the normal that proteus hormones but in
the steroid hormones itself the which
uses the intracellular receptor there is
another type of intracellular receptor
which is already bound to the DNA and
the ligand just enters and bind to the
receptor and mostly thyroid hormone
receptor Luverne x receptor retinoic
acid receptor these are those kind of
category when I talk about thyroid
hormone mechanism of action I would be
talking about all of these in very much
details so please check the playlist for
that now what we wanted to tell you that
the growth the growth factor signaling
pathway which are generally map kinase
pathway or pi3 Akt pathway those
signaling pathway have several steps
several kinase is associated with it so
the advantage is you can modulate that
pathway at several levels but here the
nuclear receptor signaling is
time-saving it's for quick responses and
but the downside of it it doesn't have a
property of signal amplification but
both the signaling pathways if we
compare we can understand their pros and
cons and in this case we learn that the
steroid hormone receptors are
intracellular receptors and they
directly bind to the DNA in hormone
response element upon the ligand binding
so I hope you understand the mechanism I
hope you like this video if you liked
this video give it a quick thumbs up
don't forget to Like share and subscribe
and please make sure you comment me in
the video your comments give me so much
positive motivation to make more videos
like this thank you